[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Marie scarer bonjour merci d'être là
sénatrice Deo pyéné toute nouvelle
présidente du groupe RDSE au Sénat on
est ravi de vous recevoir et vous avez
évidemment coécrit la proposition dont
on va parler dans quelques instants
romain Gaspard journaliste à La Gazette
des communes merci Romain d'être avec
nous et avec nous à distance Michel
Fournier bonjour Michel Fournier merci
d'être là vous êtes maire des Voivres
c'est dans les vuges président de
l'association des mares ruraux de France
on est ensemble puisqu'on va parler avec
vous du premier texte examiné dans cette
nouvelle session parlementaire au Sénat
un texte qui vise à lutter contre les
violences envers les élus elles sont en
constante augmentation incivilité mais
aussi violence physique comment assurer
la sécurité de nos élus y a-t-il un
risque de décourage profond qui
entraînerait une crise d'évocation et
une menace pour la démocratie locale on
va en parler avec vous et Mathias vous
nous direz ce que contient ce texte
absolument on verra les 14 mesures dans
le texte on verra ça dans quelques
instants avant d'entamer ce débat qu'on
va entamer dans quelques minutes je vous
propose de regarder le témoignage d'un
maire qui a été victime de menace il
s'appelle Pascal schneeder maire de Neu
maisons en meurt et Moselle deux fois
menacé de mort en 3 ans pas de
condamnation pénale il dénonce un
isolement des maires face à ces menaces
Jérôme Rabier N emmène à sa rencontre
Pascal schneeder est maire de Neu
maisons dans l'agglomération de Nancy et
en seulement 3 ans de mandat il a déjà
porté plein deux fois pour des menaces
de
M la première fois l'habitant qui l'a
menacé a été déclaré irresponsable
pénalement en raison de troubles
schizophrènes mais l'an dernier une
autre personne l'a menacé cette fois-ci
dans son bureau en cause une demande de
logement à shlm qui était bloquée cette
personne s lâché sur les réseaux sociaux
et ce qui a fait que cette fâcherie nous
a amené à devoir l'inviter pour qu'on
ait une explication sur le sujet qu'on
lui dise pourquoi on en était là et
pourquoi ce dossier n'avançait pas suite
à ça et dans ce bureau même ce monsieur
s'est emporté puisque nous n'avions pas
plus de solutions à lui offrir on
voulait juste lui expliquer ce monsieur
s'est emporté
nous a menacé de mort également pour la
seconde fois et là vertement et a
renchéri une fois ça sorti un peu
précipité de de mon bureau à renchérri
une nouvelle fois sur les réseaux
sociaux pour nous promettre de nous
faire la peau qu'il était équipé en
conséquence qu'il avait une grande
famille pour le faire et qu'il ne nous
lerait pas tant qu'il nait pas un
logement social et pourtant le jugement
est tombé le mois dernier cet individu
qui vit à moins de 300 m du domicile du
maire a été relaxé une déception pour le
premier magistrat de la commune mais on
attendait enfin j'attendais l'équipe
municipale aussi attendait des sanctions
symbolique mais mais forte pas forte en
en terme d'importance mais forte sur le
plan de l'image que ça pouvait donner et
et là on est très loin du compte sans
remettre en cause évidemment le principe
d'une justice libre qui doit être rendue
librement par ces juges mais c'est une
justice enfin du moins les jugements qui
m'interpellent quelque peu sil se
réjouit que le gouvernement et les
autorités locales soient au chevet des
Maes Pascal schneeder attend du concret
faute de quoi il ne s'agirait selon lui
que d'un coup de communication non rien
ne bouge je peux pas vous dire que
aujourd'hui je me sens mieux qu'hier non
ce n'est pas vrai non non non au
contraire l'ence l'absence de jugement
sévère l'égard des des deux personnes
concernées m'inquiète encore plus
qu'avant les jugements d'ailleurs mais
pas question pour lui de démissionner il
reste déterminé c'est pour ses proches
que la situation a été plus compliquée
notamment quand il a eu 15 jours de
protection policière suite au m j'ai
bénéficié de ma de ma protection
policière et j'en j'en suis ravi encore
aujourd'hui euh je n'avais rien avouer à
mon épouse pour pas que ça que ça
complique la situation sauf que quand
vous avez deux gendarmes en faction
devant chez vous pendant 15 jours votre
épouse légitimement se pose des
questions lors de la dernière réunion
consacrés à ce sujet par la préfecture
ils étaient de nombreux élus à
s'inquiéter sur ce point et à
s'interroger pour la suite la crise
d'évocation peut s'installer encore plus
durablement ça c'est un vrai sujet faut
s'en inquiéter c'est peut-être ça le
plus grave des sujets des mèes comme moi
qui lutent il y en aura toujours des
maires appelés à devenir maires ça peut
être plus compliqué demain si on dépint
le paysage qui est vrai comme je viens
de le faire Pascal schneeder n'est pas
encore de ceux qui sont résignés et
Contin continuent de mener son mandat
peu importe les ala à ses yeux
démissionner serait la pire façon de
donner raison à ses agresseurs
Marie SC comment vous réagissez face à
ce témoignage de ce maire qui a été
victime d'agression c'est difficile à
entendre et difficile à comprendre aussi
comment on peut aujourd'hui rendre
responsable maire de tous ses malheurs
ses propres malheur c'est la difficulté
aujourd'hui qu'on les citoyens et qu'on
a face aux citoyens de ces comportements
où il faut tout tout de suite et et où
l'intérêt général est pas forcément la
première démotivations des citoyens mais
plutôt les intérêts par particulier
c'est cette société de l'individualisme
qu'on est en train de de voir naître et
qui qui est difficile et et les maires
en font les frais aujourd'hui en
première ligne ce sont les premiers
premières lignes de de la démocratie
locale et ils sont
aujourd'hui bien bien en prise avec ces
sujets les maires et leur famille parce
que il le dit dans le témoignage il en a
pas parlé à son épouse pour pas
l'inquiéter mais mais il y a pas que que
le maire il y a le maire évidemment mais
ça rejiller aussi sur sur les proches
des mares tout à fait tout à fait on a
on a eu des témoignages alors j'ai eu la
chance de présider une mission
d'information ces derniers mois nous
avons rendu notre rapport au mois de
juillet avec Matthieu Darnaud rapporteur
sénateur de l'Ardèche nous avons
interviewé des maires qui ont
démissionné c'est sur l'avenir de la
commune et du Maou tout à fait nous
avons auditionné des maires qui avaient
subi des agressions et c'est vrai que
l'entourage aussi empathie et c'est
difficile pour pour eux aussi de faire
subir ça à leur famille ouais il y a il
y a une forme d'isolement oui de ces
mères aujourd'hui oui de plus en plus
forte oui je pense oui il y a une forme
d'isolement euh une un sentiment
d'abandon et euh parce que les réponses
pénales ne sont pas toujours à la
hauteur ouis on va y venir on va y venir
parce qu'il y a une phrase aussi très
forte dans dans ce reportage romain euh
ces violen ces menaces elles sont en
augmentation oui c'est le le le
reportage est l'illustration parfaite du
du phénomène euh on voit sur les
chiffres 1914 agressions alors souvent
c'est plutôt des outrages c'est plutôt
des insultes les les agressions
physiques c'est 9 % mais c'est quand
même 172 agressions depuis le début de
l'année donc on est on est sur sur
quelque chose un phénomène pas
négligeable et qui est en augmentation
et derrière c'est le pouvoir d'agir des
mères aussi qui est en jeu parce que
c'est d'être face à des citoyens et de
pas pouvoir apporter de réponse et et
ces agressions il y en a encore une
assez marquante et assez violente qui
s'est passée dans la Meuse à la fin du
mois où c'est un maire qui qui face à un
dépôt sauvage a été hospitalisé parce
que agressé on se souvient du maire de
signe en 2019 qui est mort à cause de ça
et donc c'est un phénomène qui prend de
l'ampleur il est pas majeur dans le sens
où on n'est pas sur chaque mère va pas
se faire agresser au coin de la rue mais
par contre on est sur un phénomène en
augmentation d'année en année et qui
inquiète les élus de plus en plus et qui
inquiète les élus au-delà simplement des
maères aussi des conseillers municipaux
aussi des maires adjoints qui est qui
est vraiment assez large dans la dans la
communauté noté des élus on va dire ça
comme ça on va aller voir Michel
Fournier qui est président de
l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France merci Michel Fournier d'être avec
nous est-ce que les maires ruraux sont
particulièrement touchés par ces
violences
oui
bonjour Alors je je viens d'entendre les
différentes les différentes choses là
mais il est certain que le maire rural
il a l'avantage et l'inconvénient de la
proximité ça veut dire que forcément il
est on l'a déjà souligné et beaucoup
l'ont souligné il est apporté de gifle
donc ça c'est c'est c'est une chose il
faut aussi se dire aussi quelque chose
c'est que la société est de plus en plus
violente c'est c'est pas propre au
mèrein pour beaucoup de gens qui
exercent une responsabilité que ça soit
enseignant ou autre hein on voit même
Pompi médecin et cetera il y a toujours
et il y a de plus en plus de réponses
violentes par par contre en ce qui
concerne les maires c'est sûr que le
ministre de la
Justice aujourd'hui enfin il y a de 3
ans maintenant a pris une décision pour
que effectivement plus rien ne soit
classé sans suite ça c'était une
première réponse c'est-à-dire au niveau
des procureurs il n'y avait plus où il y
avait mission de plus classer sans suite
mais c'est après que ça va pas ça a été
souligné par madame la sénatrice et il y
a effectivement dans la réponse de la
justice c'est-à-dire les le jugement et
le le maire l'a souligné le maire de
neuve maison et bien le les jugements ne
sont pas à la hauteur de de Ben tout
simplement de du constat qui a été fait
au départ on on va parler Michel
Fournier on va parler de la réponse
pénale dans quelques instants mais
d'abord sur le constat est-ce que les
maires ruraux qui sont forcément dans
des communes plus petites donc peut-être
plus facilement apporter de BAFF
apporter d'enguelade sont plus touchés
et quels sont les sujets de friction et
est-ce que vous constatez une
augmentation une aggravation des
violences quelles sont les remontées que
vous avez de des ma eururau oui ben bien
sûr qu' il y a de enfin il y a plus de
réponses violentes parce que aussi
aujourd'hui on sait que on on on on
indique au maire et on leur demande
systématiquement de porter plainte parce
que il y avait aussi une toute une
époque moi-même j'ai connu vous savez
j'ai j'ai certain nombre de mandats et
et bien je peux vous dire que les
agressions ai eu à peu près trois ou
quatre dans enfin peut-être plus même je
sais plus dans le lors de mes mandats
mais on on ce que ce que l'on faisait
pas auparavant c'est-à-dire on ne
déposait pas plainte parce que on se
disait de toute façon ça va il y aura
pas de suite aujourd'hui c'est c'est
beaucoup plus précis dans la mesure où
effectivement on incite à déposer
plainte mais c'est vrai aussi que encore
une fois la la violence elle est là et
cette violence là bien on l'a subi de
plein fois quand on est mère d'une
commune rurale parce que on est à
proximité et c'est SR des alors il y a
les dépôts sauvages il y a il y a
surtout ça a été souligné il y a surtout
le fait quand on ne répond pas
à j'allais dire un besoin privé un
besoin personnel et bien ce n'est plus
et ce n'est pas accepté autrement dit le
sens de la collectivité est un peu perdu
quand même restez avec nous Michel fer
on va parler de la réponse pénale mar
c'est important ce que dit Michel
Fournier est-ce que aujourd'hui
finalement les maires ils subissent une
évolution de la société une augmentation
de l'individualisme et aujourd'hui le
maire il doit quelque chose à cet
administré c'est comme ça qu'il est vu
c'est comme ça qu'il est vu oui je pense
que c'est il est là pour eux il est là
pour les servir et et ce que dit
monsieur le Président est juste
l'individualisme comme j'ai pu le dire
et puis aussi ce que vous avez dit sur
le pouvoir d'agir alors ça je veux
passer quelques quelques secondes dessus
parce qu'aujourd'hui je dirais que les
maires deviennent les punching ball de
l'État à l'échelle de leur commune ils
se retrouvent avec des compétences
imposées des compétences qui sont pas
forcément ils doivent annoncer par
exemple sur une décision d'urbanisme
voilà c'est l'État qui décide quand la
commune est au règlement national
d'urbanisme c'est la commune qui c'est
l'État qui décide et c'est au maire
d'annoncer aux citoyens que son permis
est refusé et là c'est là aussi où le
maire n'a plus le pouvoir d'agir sur sa
commune il n'a pas les mains libres et
il devient un véritable le punching ball
aussi de l'État sur sur à l'échelle de
sa commune et de son territoire d'autres
décisions aussi qui sont liées d'autres
compétences qui sont lié à
l'intercommunalité par exemple et dont
ils n'ont pas la la ils n'ont pas la
main dessus et et ça aussi les citoyens
le savent pas forcément et et c'est lui
qui est le premier en première ligne
comme au rugby c'est c'est lui qui doit
assumer les coups et d'où votre texte et
et et on va en parler hein puisque c'est
cet après-midi Mathias qu'il est examiné
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat oui c'est une
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
sécurité des élus locaux et la
protection des maires déposé le 26 mai
dernier par le président de la
commission des lois le sénateur her durô
François Noël buffet cette initiative
sénatoriale est une réaction rapide à
l'incendie volontaire du domicile du
maire de Saint-Brévin Yannick morz vous
vous en souvenez c'était le 17 mai alors
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce texte alors
elle comprend 14 mesures cette
proposition de loi elles sont divisées
en trois axes première axe consolider
l'arsenal répressif en cas de violence
d'injure ou de harcèlement à l'encontre
des élus il y est notamment question
d'aligner les peines sur le régime déjà
existant pour d'autres personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique 2ème
point améliorer la prise en charge des
élus dans le cadre de leur mandat comme
en comme en campagne on parle là de la
couverture des frais d'avocat par
exemple d'assurance en cas de dommage ou
même par exemple des dépenses de
sécurisation c'est-à-dire un vigile ou
un agent de sécurité privée enfin
dernier volet là c'est renforcé la prise
en compte des réalités des mandats
électifs locaux par les acteurs
judiciaires et étatiques la proposition
entend ici fluidifier les relations
entre les procureurs les préfets et les
élus à travers des rencontres ou la
possibilité par exemple au premiers
d'assister au Conseil locaux de sécurité
et de prévention de la délinquence quels
sont les chance d'abouti alors déjà il
faut noter que c'est une proposition de
loi qui regroupe plus de 200
cosignataires majoritairement issus de
la droite du centre du groupe RDSE c'est
vrai et pourtant il semblerait qu'on
arrive à une position consensuelle euh
de pratiquement tous les bords
politiques les socialistes se sont
abstenus en commission mais pourrai
finalement voter le texte les
écologistes le voteront les communistes
aussi du côté de l'exécutif le la
ministre déléguée chargée des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité s'est dite favorable à la
proposition de loi le gouvernement
poussera également du côté de
l'Assemblée nationale pour que le texte
du Sénat soit rapidement mis à l'ordre
du jour dans les coulisses on table à
peu près sur la semaine trans
transpartisan euh début décembre pour
une mise en voie au Palais Bourbon
qu'est-ce que ce texte qu'est-ce que
votre texte apporte de plus maris carer
que les dispositifs qui ont déjà été
annoncés par le gouvernement après les
événements notamment en mai on grave
dans le marbre de la loi le l'align
l'alignement des maires sur les
aujourd'hui les les personnes qui sont
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
aujourd'hui c'est ce sont des des choses
qui sont fait dans les tribunaux avec
une attention particulière du garde des
saau effectivement qui a demandé au
magistrat d'être d'être assez sévère et
d'être assez bienveillant sur les sur
les ces affaires là aujourd'hui c'est
gravé dans le marbre cela et et moi je
CIS je crois que c'est important aussi
de reconnaître c'est une façon de
reconnaître aussi les maires comme des
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
et de de leur montrer qu'on les protège
aussi à ce titre-là et que la réponse
pénale sera peut-être plus efficace pour
revenir sur la réponse pénale on va
revenir au témoignage he qu'on a entendu
en début d'émission un sommaire Pascal
schneeder qui disait l'absence de
jugement m'inquiète encore plus qu'avant
le jugement c'est fort ça comme phrase
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la réponse
pénale elle n'est pas là lui il y a pas
eu de condamnation dans son cas on l'a
vu on en connaît beaucoup on en connaît
beaucoup sur mon département j'en
connais quelques-uns aussi où il n'y a
pas eu de réponse pénale derrière hormis
quelques rappels à la
loi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment faire exemple aussi quand on a
ses jugements quand on quand on
s'attaque à un maire on s'attaque à la
République et moi je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui que la justice prenne en
compte ces ces réalités et et fasse
alors la justice pour l'exemple mais je
pense que c'est important pour éviter à
à la suite que les maires soient plus
agressés encore il fallait aller plus
loin encore romain malgré les réponses
apportées pour le gouvernement après ce
qui s'est passé à sbrvin benah déjà il
fallait ancrer dans le marbre et dans la
loi un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont législatives donc cette PPL permet
ça après il y a deux de limites il y a
l'engorgement des tribunaux et le manque
de moyens et ça euh si on rajoute pas
des moyens il y aura toujours ce
problème là il y a une grande inégalité
selon sur quel tribunal on on tombe et
puis il y en a un autre c'est aussi
euh le manque de communication parfois
les maires et c'est cet isolement qui
était qui était dit très bien par dans
dans le reportage ils ont besoin de lien
avec le procureur de le rencontrer
d'avoir d'avoir ce cette communication
là pour sentir un soutien et dans
l'affaire de Saint-Brévin une des
critiques du maire démissionnaire c'est
ce manque de lien ce manque de soutien
du procureur et donc cette PPL est le le
le plan contre les violences des du
gouvernement essaie de d'améliorer ça
améliorer cette communication et donner
un vrai lien entre le système judiciaire
et les maires pour qu'ils se sentent
soutenu et des fois ça paraît symbolique
mais c'est pas rien pour un maire
surtout d'une petite commune de savoir
qu' peut joindre un procureur qui qui va
avoir une communication et qui va avoir
un soutien du préfet Michel Fournier sur
la réponse pénale c'est important que ça
soit gravé dans la loi oui oui c'est
important est-ce que ce qui vient d'être
dit on parle de communication j'ai fait
une proposition qui qui je sais pas si
elle doit être prise dans une loi mais
il serait important puisque nous sommes
au PJ nous avons une fonction nous
représentons l'état il serait important
que à la nouvelle mandature il y ait une
prestation de serment qui soit faite euh
au tribunal par les maires de manière à
fixer vraiment c'est c'est une
symbolique certes mais à fixer les les
les les choses et que la population ce
cette cette prestation qu'elle soit
publique de manière à ce que la
population et bien elle se rend compte
que effectivement le rôle que nous avons
à jouer il est un rôle de représentant
de l'État dans dans la commune et ça
c'est une proposition qui est approuvée
par l'ensemble de de mon ass Association
des Maires Ruraux qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette proposition Marie je
précise juste que OPJ c'est officier de
police judiciaire c'est c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant que que
après bon la séparation de de de l'état
des pouvoirs pardon de l'É des pouvoir
et et et ça paraît un peu difficile de
que les maires prêent serment au nom de
la justice voilà donc ça mais mais ça
peut être intéressant d'avoir peut-être
une action forte un symbole fort en
début de mandat lorsque les maires sont
élu euh pour aussi assoir leur leur
autorité entre entre guillemets ça peut
être ça peut être intéressant c'est
quelque chose sur laquelle il va falloir
peut-être réfléchir après il y a il y a
les questions sécuritaires et c'est
nécessaire mais ça va bien au-delà il y
a et ce que défend en particulier les m
rurau mais aussi la MF c'est le statut
de l'élu davantage de protection
davantage de formation davantage parfois
plus d'égalité dans les indemnités et
puis il y a même au-delà on disait le
pouvoir d'agir que un maire pour qu'il
s'engage pour qu'il y ait pas de crise
d'évocation euh et de et qu' ait des
candidats nouveaux et en particulier sur
les conseillers municipaux où il y a un
vrai enjeu pour dans 3 ans c'est qu'il
ait la capacité de faire des choses pour
ses habitants de d'agir et donc d'avoir
moins d'opposition là-dessus et il y a
une vraie crise du pouvoir d'agir et oui
c'est nécessaire de d'agir pour la
protection des élus mais ça ne règlera
pas une partie des tention à une partie
des problèmes qui vont bien au-delà et
qui sont dans la continuité des des
travaux et on voit il devrait y avoir
des annonce au au Congrès des mares de
France sur le statut de l'élu il faut
aller au-delà pour pouvoir régler cette
question c'est un peu un serpent de Mare
Marie oui
c'est longemps on dit qu'il va y avoir
des annonces sur le statut de l'élu
effectivement la ministre a dit qu'
qu'elles onurt lieu en novembre c'est
urgence c'est ça oui c'est il y a
urgence aujourd'hui parce que la crise
des voocation pointe pointe le nez 2026
je pense qu'il va y avoir une vraie
crise de vocation notamment dans le
milieu rural hein parce que dans les
petites communes et pour avoir été mè
pendant 16 ans d'une petite commune je
sais ce que c'est que de que d'être 24h/
24 tous les jours de l'année sur le pont
pour ses concitoyens euh on y arrive
petit à petit parce que au fur et à
mesure des des années on discute du
statut de l'élu on discute aussi euh de
toutes les protections qu'on peut leur
apporter nous nous-même avec le RDSE
nous avons déposé une loi en 2021 pour
permettre aux associations nationales
d'élus de se porter partie civil lors
des procès au pénal à l'initiative de
notre collègue Nathalie de lâre donc ça
c'est le RDSE qui qui a porté cette
cette loi elle porte nous avons
aujourd'hui une aussi une discussion
avec un interne de notre groupe avec
Henri Cabanel aussi qui veut travailler
sur le statut de l'élu suite à la
mission aussi qui est sénateur aussi de
notre groupe sur la aussi le le suite à
aussi une mission qu'il a effectué sur
la citoyenneté l'engagement citoyen donc
voilà il y a des choses qui se font les
propositions de la PPL de de que nous
examineront ce soir elles viennent aussi
d'une mission qui avait été faite en
2019 suite à l'accident au décès du
maire de CNE présidé par Philippe Bas
avec la Commission des des lois donc
voilà on y travaille mais petit à petit
il faut qu'on concrétise tout ça et
cette proposition de loi elle est là
pour concrétiser et vous parliez de
cette crise d'évocation et évidemment
c'est le sujet on entendait tout à
l'heure le témoignage he dans le
reportage de de Pascal schneder qui
disait bon pour les maires qui sont là
on est déterminé on se bat mais ce qui
qui étant c'est pour ceux qui sont
appelés à devenir maire ça vous inquiète
en 2026 les élections municipales qui a
de nombreuses communes qui vous qui se
retrouvent sans candidat oui oui ça
m'inquiète et et je pense que ça va être
le
cas on a aujourd'hui avec notre mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
et du maire ressenti
vraiment cette cette désespérance des
élus alors elle est multiple il y a
beaucoup de facteurs il y a bien sûr les
relations avec la population les
citoyens qui ont qui changent et moi qui
étais jusqu'en 2017 j'ai vu en 6 ans
l'évolution aujourd'hui du mandat de
Mare je je je reconnais plus le mandat
que j'ai eu moi il y a même si je l'ai
abandonné ben parce qu'il y a beaucoup
plus de pression pour les maires il y a
beaucoup plus d'exigences de l'État il y
a beaucoup plus de difficultés avec la
population les citoyensnes dans le
relationnel il y a l'appréhension aussi
de
l'intercommunalité on a du mal
aujourd'hui une commune elle a du mal à
se situer dans son intercommunalité et
l'intercommunalité a du mal aussi à
prendre sa place et c'est tous ces
constats qu'on a fait dans notre mission
et c'était c était vraiment intéressant
mais inquiétant parce qu'on sent que
2026 sera difficile pour les communes
rurales et justement Michel Fournier ce
sont des remontées que vous avez à
l'association des des mares ruraux vous
êtes inquiet pour 2026 dans les communes
rurales comme le disait Marie scarer
oui déjà deux choses effectivement la
fonction de maire a changé je je suis
maire depuis 89 donc j'ai vu l'évolution
du mandat et puis je voudrais signaler
aussi que ce statut de l'élu que que
l'on évoque ça ça fait quand même près
de 30 ans que l'on se bat et notamment
au niveau des communes rurales parce que
c'est là que c'est c'est le plus le le
plus important parce que c'est là que
c'est le plus difficile d'exercer une
fonction professionnelle et une fonction
d'élu aujourd'hui et c'est cela qui qui
qui qui fera que il y aura des
difficultés peut-être à s'engager en
2026 mais le plus grave il est même pas
là il est que quand des des gens
s'engage et qu'ils veulent continuer à
exercer une profession et notamment des
des jeunes et bien au bout de peut-être
un ou 2 ans et bien il y en a beaucoup
qui démissionnent parce que ils
s'aperçoivent qu'ils peuvent pas
concilier les deux et et c'est nous
c'est nous qui le vivons ça et je c'est
bien de que ça soit annoncé au niveau de
de de l'AMF mais là ça fait quand même
30 ans qu'on se bat là-dessus et
j'aimerais quand même aussi que on le
soulligne parce que c'est nous qui
sommes concernés en premier sinon et
bien on aurait pu se battre au à au
auparavant l'ensemble des maires avait
la la main là-dessus ça c'est un peu
faux euh romain on avait entendu déjà en
2020 cette crise d'évocation il y avait
des inquiétudes sur le fait que des
communes pourraient se retrouver sans
candidats il y en a eu un peu plus d'une
centaine je crois est-ce que là en 2026
ça va ça va être pire euh la crise à mon
avis elle est pas sur elle est pas
tellement elle est un peu mais sur les
maires en place parce que on voit qu'ils
ont une envie de faire et ils sont aux
manettes mais c'est plutôt dans les
candidats à venir et des endroits où des
maires vont arrêter et pour les
remplacer pour avoir de nouveaux
candidats pour avoir un renouvellement
pour des jeunes générations là il y a
une vraie inquiétude et encore plus au
niveau des conseillers municipaux des
maires adjoints parce que les démissions
c'est quand même par an 13000 à 15000
sur 500000 conseillers municipaux donc
c'est pas négligeable on voit que c'est
en augmentation régulière d'année en
année et donc là il y a un vrai enjeu et
derrière après ce que disait Michel
Fournier ça pose la question du cumul
avec un un un emploi à côté et ça on
voit que c'est de plus en plus difficile
et donc c'est pas du tout le chemin qui
est pris mais au Sénat il y a une PPL
socialiste
pour faire un CDD des MRES ou
transformer la rémunération et ça c'est
un vrai débat qui qui qui qui est latant
et qui n'est pas tranché jusqu'à
aujourd'hui un dernier mot mais r
effectivement il y a la question du
cumul entre un métier et la fonction et
la question des indemnités égalementou
je pense que c'est plus la question de
libérer du temps pour quelqu'un qui est
actif et et qui veut exercer un mandat
de maire que l'indamité moi je suis pas
pour la fonctionnarisation du maire
aujourd'hui un maire il fait ça aussi il
fait pas ça pour les indemnités c'est
pas vrai vous trouverez pas beaucoup de
maires qui font ça pour l'indemnité
parce que sinon il le ferait pas vu le
montant des indamnités je pense que
c'est surtout le la possibilité de
libérer du temps et c'est sur ce sujet
là qu'il faut
travailler merci merci d'avoir été avec
nous pour restez avec nous jusqu'à la
fin de cette émission si vous voulez
bien on va revenir IR évidemment sur
l'actualité du côté d'Israël c'est à la
Une de quasiment toute la presse
régionale on va le voir avec vous dans
quelques instants Mathias mais d'abord
on va aller à Marseille retrouver
Françoise vernaard merci d'être avec
nous rédactrice en chef adjointe de la
Marseillaise et à la Une de La
Marseillaise Françoise cette
manifestation qui avait lieu hier en
soutien au peuple
israélien oui tout à fait c'était à
l'appel donc du CRIF et c'est une
manifestation c'était plutôt un
rassemblement un rassemblement qui s'est
fait dans le recueillement et et le
silence beaucoup de dignité beaucoup de
tristesse aussi puisqu'il y avait
évidemment de nombreux élus il faut
noter la diversité dans les étiquettes
politiques et aussi la diversité parmi
les citoyens alors Marseille abrite la
deuxème communauté juif de France he
80000 marseillaisin sont sont sont juifs
donc ce qui se passe actuellement en
Israël et et en Palestine et me et et
fait vraiment
beaucoup de de de mal à la communauté
juive et à tous les marseillais euh il y
a aussi des messages de de paix puisque
parmi les personnes qui se sont
rassemblées je rappelle dans le silence
il y a donc michaelll un jeune homme qui
nous dit qu'aujourd'hui il y a deux
victimes le peuple israélien et le
peuple palestinien et puis nous avons
une particularité à Marseille aussi
c'est que nous avons une association qui
s'appelle Marseille espérance qui
rassemble toutes les communautés
religieuses hein et euh qui lance un
appel au à cesser les combats euh
redoutant évidemment euh d'autres
victimes puisqueaujourd'hui on est dans
une situation euh euh dont on ne sait
pas quelle sera l'issue en tout cas euh
avec ce qui se passe actuellement
toujours notamment à Gaza merci beaucoup
merci François ern d'avoir été avec nous
et Gaza justement c'est la Une de La
Marseillaise Gaza sous le feu euh c'est
à lire ce matin dans votre journal merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous Mathias
on va continuer évidemment à parler
d'Israël c'est à la une de la presse
[Musique]
régionale et Mathias forcément c'est la
ripost israélienne à Gaza qui occupe la
une ce matin oui énormément de photos
choc à la une de nos journaux dans nos
régions Orian sous la bannière de cette
riposte d'Israël l'Alsace retient ses
images de la bande de Gaza en ruine pour
le Dauphine libéré c'est ce panage de
fumée dans le ciel Gazaoui synonyme de
Bombard même terrible cliché en Une de
presse auocéance au mardi un ciel rouge
dans la nuit pour l'Est pour l'Est
Républicain avec le redoublement des
frappes aérienne et enfin des colonnes
de blindé en première page de l'union de
reins et de la Dépêche du Midi qui
s'interroge très légitimement la guerre
jusqu'où même thème et un autre sujet
qui préoccupe la presse régionale les
otages du Hamas oui c'est le choix de
sud-ouest et de la Provence aujourd'hui
le journal Bordelet placard de ses
visages de personnes porté disparu
notamment certains présents au Festival
de musique électronique de REIM à
quelques kilomètres seulement de la
bande de Gaza où a eu lieu une attaque
samedi au petit matin la Provence
recueille elle le témoignage du mari
d'une franco-israélienne de 32 ans sans
nouvell de son épouse également présente
au festival on l'a évoqué un peu plus
tôt l'émotion était vive dans plusieurs
villes de France il y a eu effectivement
de nombreux rassemblements on vient de
l'entendre partout en France on a parlé
de celui de Paris éminemment politique
les dernières nouvelles d'alsas
retiennent celui de Strasbourg devant le
Conseil de l'Europe où se sont réunis
plus de 600 personnes VarMatin et les
journaux du groupe reviennent en détail
sur les différents rassemblements sur la
Côte d'Azur de Marseille à Nice en
passant par fréus allez d'autres sujets
pour terminer on tourne cette page
Israël un autre événement pas plus
joyeux oui cor ce matin titre nuit bleue
à la lumière du jour pratiquement 11 ans
que l'île de Beauté n'avait pas connu
pareille violence au total les autorités
locales ont recensé 27 attentats
revendiqués immédiatement par le Front
de libération nationale Corse parmi
lesquels des résidences secondaires des
villas et maisons en construction mais
également un bâtiment public des
attaques violentes brutal qui
interviennent quelques semaines
seulement après la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron et la volonté de construire
ensemble le présent et l'avenir comme
évoqué par Gilles séoni chef de
l'exécutif insulaire on termine
rapidement avec un anniversaire allez un
triste anniversaire Orian dis an que
l'abattoire gade de lampul guimiliao
dans le Finistère a annoncé sa fermeture
avec lui la suppression de pratiquement
1000 emploi le Télégramme revient sur
cet épisode qui avait fait l'effet d'une
bombe dans le département et dont la
lutte syndicale avait largement été
relayée dans la presse nationale merci
Mathias merci pour cette presse merci
maris carer d'être venu on suivra
évidemment l'examen du texte tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle du Sénat merci
Romain la Une de La Gazette des communes
recrutement comment attirer les futurs
policiers municipaux il y a pas que les
Mair qui cherch des des candidats oui
c'est et puis c'est c'est sur comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à les attirer la la
la la bataille entre collectivités pour
les attirer et puis comment est-ce que
leur mission évolue avec celle de la
police nationale et on arrive à les
faire coopérer c'est à lire dans la
Gazette merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec Thomas
HUG pour sens public on se retrouve
demain très bonne
journée